we don't know how to go that fast yet to
mars uh but i guess other people are
looking into those
new technologies to get faster so matt
what we need is a wormhole between earth
and mars you just step through it it's
it and enjoy it and then and then and
then the you know the corona mass
ejection comes you just step back to
earth protected by our atmosphere see
it's easy when you put it that way my my
idea was just to move mars closer
[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
today we're going to talk about
spacesuits
which or we could retitle this how to
not die in space and i've got with me
co-host matt kirschen matt good to have
you man
it's good to be here i i'm i'm at home
right now i'm back home which is uh
another way to not die in space
but being on earth it's a way to not die
in space i think that's staying safely
in los angeles that's my tip for this
episode so this is kind of a hybridized
uh it's going to be sort of an info show
on spacesuit space street design what is
protecting us from why why is it
necessary
and then we're gonna blend in some
cosmic queries in the second and third
segment so
i look forward to this not well i know a
little bit about spacesuits i don't know
nearly enough to carry this show
so we combed the landscape of people
with this kind of expertise and they
exist
okay
and we found professor anna diaz-arties
anna welcome to star talk
hi thank you so much for having me here
this is great i love it you're an
assistant professor in the department of
aerospace engineering at texas a m
and you have developed or in the process
of developing a new spacesuit
and it's called the smart suit so i want
to totally get into that but in this
moment you're coming to us from
barcelona is that correct
right i'm i'm originally from spain
although i was born in canada islands
but i'm now in barcelona my husband is
from from barcelona so i'm here
visiting some family okay i love the
canary islands we have some telescopes
there uh there's volcanic and there's
wine there too there's some there's a
wine industry so we got to bring you
back we'll talk about the canary islands
that's a whole lot a whole other show
and uh and matt you're not just my
co-host comedian you host your own
podcast probably science and i've been a
guest i've been on a guest on that show
and you have indeed and uh yeah so we've
got that connection the the connection i
have with anna is i've sent in my
designs for spacesuits many times to
universities around the world no reply
so far
but uh
yeah i i i i she'll tell you why
yeah
i'm wondering if if the fishbowl is not
using high enough quality material i
think cause like because i'm i'm using
target you know just like a standard
target fishbowl but maybe you need to go
to one of like the specialist pet supply
stores oh yeah i mean the fishbowl
inverted on your head is that what
you're saying as a helmet yeah exactly
you know that's
it's fishbowl and jumpsuit what more do
you need i can't imagine i think that's
the end of the science right we're done
there you go
okay so anna why in just that moment was
matt a complete idiot
no no anna what kills you in space why
can't we just hold our breath until we
get to our destination
right so there are there could be many
things that can kill you in space but if
i have to pick one i would say
you know we do have a lack of atmosphere
there isn't any pressure putting on your
body
so that lack of pressure
is actually going to make all your
fluids basically become
gas and then you're gonna boil in space
uh pretty quickly
wow okay so that's not even about
whether you can hold your breath
no actually uh if you hold your breath
like that's not a good idea because that
oxygen about that um
fluid that you're holding it's gonna
expand also be because of the lack of
pressure and and then
you know that it's not gonna be good for
your lungs if you've that exactly
i've obviously i've never been to space
but i have gone scuba diving and one of
the very first things they tell you that
they drum into you
very many times is you must not hold
your breath as you come up to the
surface for that exact reason because
you've you've breathed in air at high
pressure down in the depths and then as
you come up to the lower pressure on the
surface you could basically
burst right so anna that sounds like
exactly the same problem is that correct
that's i was going to say that's exactly
the same problem it's just the other way
around
when we go into a spacesuit we're
generally going into lower pressures
compared to to the spacecraft that we're
having and there are many reasons why we
want to go to lower pressures and one of
them is mobility we can talk about it
but then if we think about scuba diving
the problem is not when you go down but
it's actually when you go up because you
go for higher pressure to lower
pressures and this is why i'm not a
diver unfortunately but um this is why
you need to to do all these
waiting times and you cannot just go up
to the surface really quickly you need
to stage those
those things up like so so anna how did
you get into this i mean when you were a
little little child and said i want to
design spacesuit i mean like who who
does this
did you watch some movie was like did
you visit someplace how does one become
a spacesuit designer maybe that's that's
really what the question is
yeah so i am
i'm i'm just a traditional aerospace
engineer um just a regular aerospace
you bump into engineering on the street
all the time
regular aerospace engineers
i've always been fascinated with space
and
and yes there was a movie it was
actually um
a tv series from the earth to the moon i
don't know if you remember that yes of
course yes yes like 1997 if i remember
correctly and
you know we didn't have netflix or
anything at the time so you just had to
be there
on saturdays at 7 00 pm otherwise you
missed the whole thing or wasn't
streaming yeah
yeah yeah
and yeah it was at the time that i was
finishing high school and just like what
do i want to do with my life and such so
so yes thoroughly i said this is what i
want to do i want to do space and
and i started working my way into that
so i went into our space engineer and
and then i went to to industry for a
while so i didn't do research right
after
my degree
um
let's be clear matt if you didn't know
this
she could go on for more education or
she can make a boatload of money going
into industry immediately that is the
choice is that correct anna tell fess up
this is what happened correct oh well
um i i was launching rockets i was in
operations and unrelated to space so so
very far away from research but still
space related
um and i was there for a while i was
there for a few years that's true
okay okay that's that's always
that's always been my issue with you
know whenever anyone to take us
marginally off topic whenever anyone
there's like you know climate change or
evolution arguments and there was like
these
these academic elites like do you have
any idea how unelite academics are
better
compared to what they could be doing
with them how much money in their brains
how much money they don't make compared
to how much money they could
they've turned down the c-suite for for
hacky sacks and sandals you know
so yeah so i'm impressed that this tv
series uh had an impact on you because
do we really know how much influence our
media has on people's ambitions i don't
think we think about it enough we just
think of it as entertainment but my gosh
if it puts you on a path to where you
are now that people need to know that it
did and i i feel like i've told this
story before i feel like i'm always
repeating myself but certainly was a
game changer for me and another time
also we didn't have this this huge
social media or social
presence um
so so that that's something that i
definitely try to contribute and with
this postcast and and
you know trying to tell especially
little girls and and
you know stem and
girls in particular because they
you know has been shown they they sort
of start not becoming interested in
understanding these siblings anymore so
so i'm trying to do my part from that
right right right right
so so okay so um getting back to
the inventory of all that will kill you
in space so so one of them is your blood
begins to boil
and out gas okay that can't be good
for what's going on inside your skin so
what about the temperatures
you start getting very cold um to the
point that eventually you will freeze
but i i i believe you will die way
before that
you will be holding me worry about
freezing
so the temperature will just preserve
the corpse that's already there
yeah you wouldn't die because of
asphyxiation
and in in two minutes or less
uh and then you know start getting colds
and eventually you will be like a freeze
rock in there i i don't think will
happen very very quickly but it will
eventually happen
yeah because all the heat has to still
come out of your body and that that
would take time i guess but right but
wait so so
do you
do asphyxiate before your blood boils
what happens first
well i i don't have a experience with
this thankfully yeah i guess i guess you
can't just put a person out there and
say will you be a test case
right
right so i've been reading a little bit
about it too to see well it's let's see
what we think this will happen but i i
believe you will asphyxiate first and
you will pass out uh first and then
eventually die 30 seconds later
because you don't have any
any more oxygen going anywhere because
there is no
no oxygen to
to take from and also your blood is not
liquid anymore it's not bringing oxygen
to your
tissues anymore
so so this is a matter of minutes
this is a matter of minutes
yes so so all right so here's my here's
what i really a question i really wanted
to get to uh uh i grew up a little bit
before you or a lot before you and
astronauts wore spacesuits so i didn't
think to myself i need to go into
spacesuit design because they already
had them so did you see a flaw or a need
that others didn't
in space suit design for it to attract
you as one of its students and then
ultimately one of its researchers
yeah yeah and i have to give all the
credit to my phd advisor one of my phd
advisors dr david newman and this is how
i i did get into spacesuit
design um
and sort of
going back to to that i was in industry
then i decided to go back to academia
and get a phd and i was lucky enough to
get into mit what i started working with
dr david newman
and she she has been doing spaceship
research you know what anna it wasn't
luck all right if you're good he'll take
you there's no luck
involved now let's be clear about this
okay okay
i'll reword that sentence for you they
realized how important i would be to
their group so they brought me on okay
now pick it up from there go that's it
that's it so i joined this amazing group
of individuals
and i i put my first two years in grad
school i i worked on a project on
spacesuits and trying to understand
um how humans interact with these
spacesuits so the human spaces
interaction like spacesuit as a system
you put this system around a human and
this human has to move
um and not get injures and being able to
do all these tasks right because they
did look a little bulky on the moon that
looked like that's a lot of space suits
they wear in there yeah
right so these these injury aspects it
was the one that i started looking into
at the time and unfortunately it's
really hard to move inside the
spacesuits it's like this big
pressurized balloon that causes a lot of
problems and musculoskeletal issues and
lots of astronauts actually had
surgeries in their shoulders
because of the spacesuits it's a big big
issue that maybe you know we don't think
often about it um and this is how it got
first exposed to to start thinking about
all these issues with spacesuits
okay so now that's it so
so what we've seen um before we go to a
break uh we've seen
new design spacesuits
uh like a spacex i guess those look kind
of even stylish right and they're not so
bulky as we saw the astronauts going to
the moon where um so
does anyone care like what they look
like is their style involved as well
there is but before getting into that
the space to the spacex spacesuits these
are spacesuits designed for
inside these spacecraft so these are iva
spaces intravehicular activity
and the bulky ones that you are imagined
when going back to the moon and all
those big ones these ones are evas of
extraparticular activity so these are
very very different
type of spacesuits and it's normal than
the
the ones for inside the spacecraft are
way way thinner and way way oh i
understand that okay about that okay so
matt i heard tell that
this extra vehicular activity
term
nasa has finally at some level
simply called it spacewalking okay
they've just cut out yeah there's too
many acronyms already for two minutes
too many syllables just just tell it
like it is space walk but then they're
floating really they're really space
floating so
i never really wanted
for now they are just loading but when
we are going to the moon we need other
things no she's ready okay excuse me
okay
excuse me i don't mean to hold you back
okay
go into the one all right so do you
think much and we'll get more of this in
the other segments do you think much
about how the role of the spacesuit
depending on how strong the gravity is
on the object you're going to use it so
on the moon it's like one-sixth gravity
right so the suits they wore on them you
know the apollo astronauts were very
heavy on earth
and but when you divide by six it's not
it's not so bad
so
i presume there's a different design for
what would be a moon suit versus a mars
suit where mars you away like 40 of your
of your current weight so how do you
think about the the gravity field that
you're in
yeah i know that that's a great question
and i don't think we
we have been thinking about that
very much because it's not like we go to
different gravity levels every day and
we can just pick the gravity level that
we want
but
but yeah certainly now
we are starting to think about or you
know the last few years to think about
moon
moon spacesuits and um
i i
i
i think they they
want to do those spaces a little bit
lighter
right because a spacesuit that might be
too heavy for mars
might be just right for the moon i guess
that's really all i'm commenting on here
yeah yeah so somebody has to go in there
and and figure that out well let me take
a quick break and i just want to talk a
little bit more about the design of
current spacesuits and any specific
changes you are making to them or any
more more interestingly i think any
particular innovations that no one even
thought to do
that would make going into space that
much more pleasurable than anyone had
experienced before so we're on star talk
all about spacesuit so we'll get to
cosmic queries in a minute and i'm with
my co-host matt kirschen and dr anna
diaz artiles aerospace engineer and
expert on spacesuits when star talk
continues
we're back star talk
cosmic hybrid cosmic queries edition
we're really trying to learn about
spacesuits
and we have
one of the world's experts on it uh
professor anna diaz-artides
at the texas a m department of aerospace
engineering uh a m of course stands for
agriculture and mechanical
okay yeah so this is one of the land
grant institutions where science for
better living has been a fundamental
part of their mission statements there's
a bunch of them across the country and
you know in texas because texas has the
uh johnson space center and it's the
seat of the manned space program uh
you'd expect texas to be a little more
up on
just what you've what you're telling us
and what you specialize in because they
ca it's it's in their backyard right so
uh so i love it i love it so what about
the threat of sort of ionizing radiation
from the sun when we think of sort of
the solar wind we think of them as sort
of innocent charged particles deflected
by our magnetic field on earth and you
get the aurora
but if you're bare-assed in space or
sorry if you're in a spacesuit in space
are the spacesuits you're designing
protecting astronauts from that as well
so
that's the million-dollar question so
i'm going to start by saying i'm not a
radiation person
but what i understand from radiation
is that
we don't really know what to do about it
very much
basically we just hide whenever we know
reviews
that works every time
i apologize if there are radiation
people out there with better answers
than me i apologize for that but but
hiding works is is is what you're saying
that how do you work and we we do have
the means to know when there is
something coming from the sun and a
coronal mass ejection or a flare we we
know where those are coming and
and you know we can just stick shelter
we don't do evas or space works
when we know their
standard activity coming our way so
that's that's the way
to deal with it today as far as i know
and what's interesting is we do call it
nasa calls it space weather and just
like if there was thunderstorms outside
you would you either wouldn't go out
until it stopped or you would
bring on special protection so i guess
in
in terms of how you would react to that
information it's not fundamentally
different from what we do daily
just in life when we're preparing for
the weather
absolutely
and
the other
you know the other way to deal with it
and i guess this is more transportation
if we want to go to the moon or we want
to go to mars the other way is just go
faster so you are exposed less time
that takes more fuel it takes more fuel
to go faster and we we don't know how to
go that fast yet to mars uh but i i
guess other people are looking into
those new technologies to get faster so
matt what we need is a wormhole between
earth and mars you just step through it
it's it and enjoy it and then and then
and then the you know the coronal mass
ejection comes you just step back to
earth protected by our atmosphere
see it's easy when you put it that way
my my idea was just to move mars closer
i love your ideas matt the they're
really
i'll i'll show you i'll show you my
drawings later yeah of course
and you did it in crayon i bet right
well you've got to make an effort when
this is science
this is you know i can't just do black
and white let's exactly full-color
crayola so
there's dragons there's swords it's
really it's really colorful uh do you
have questions from our patreon members
i do so so as well as um
as well as radiation a couple of our uh
listeners uh salvatore scury and uh alan
in the stars are both asking about micro
meteorites
oh good one what are the chances of
micro sized meteors puncturing
spacesuits and what could be done to
mitigate the consequences
and how do they how does it feel to them
allen wants to know and and i want to
add to that uh is there there's
presumably a trade-off between
how much protection a suit gives you
and how less useful it becomes
because you can just put up put people
out there in a in a cement block or
whatever and they'll be fully protected
but you can't do anything in it so do
you ever think about those kind of
engineering trade-offs between safety
and utility
yeah yeah absolutely um
so in terms of protection
the spacesuit actually has
for up to 14 the current spacesuit has
up to 14 different layers
and one of them or a few of them are
just for protections and the thermal
protection and there is this this other
one who which is exactly where
um what this listener is is asking for
micrometeorites
that doesn't mean every you know there
is like a big thing coming your way it's
going to make you a hole in the spacer
that's a risk that that we know that
exists and and actually that's one of
the risks that we want to
attack from you know the kind of
smart suit things that they were doing
but um there's always a race for that
although there is some layer of
protection in there
wait so what is a smartsuit then
so this marsup is is our new new
spacesuit architecture that that we are
studying
and and we got some nasa funding to
to do some research on this
uh so this is smartsuit it's it's still
a gas pressurized suit and we haven't
talked about mechanical counter pressure
suits we can do that too
but um but basically we're adding cool
technology to the current spacesuits
and one of those technologies is to have
a self-healing membrane on the outside
of the spacer so for example in the case
i've only seen that in science fiction
movies what are you talking about uh
well this is still a little bit science
picture we are making this a reality uh
and when you have a hole you can just
put some pressure on it and and then
it's just it's just gonna self heal
and so you can come back to safety and
maybe later do better repairs but at
least it keeps you alive and you can get
back to
your shelter
okay so actually if you if you get
punctured and then you it self heals you
you be of a collecting device for
micrometeorites so
you'll be full of micro meteorites and
you just bring them all back down for
analysis that that could work right
[Laughter]
yeah well it depends if you pass through
maybe just goes away so the little bit i
know about sort of ballistic uh
protection you know clothing protection
is if you have many many layers
uh if
if an impactor hits the top layer
that energy now has to sort of work its
way to the next layer and there's a lot
of dissipation at each layer so is that
why there are so many layers to spread
the energy out
i think it's more about all the
functionalities that
we need in this spacesuit so we
definitely need um temperature
management so the first three layers are
for
something that we call the liquid
cooling and ventilation garment which is
a garment that has water circulating um
so then you can regulate if you are too
hot you can
increase the flow and then that's going
to help you with
with
temperature regulation
then you have another layer that it's
it's for the pressure it's the pressure
bladder like the one that holds the
pressure
of your spacesuit then there is another
one that it's called the strain layer
and that's
basically to avoid
the bladder to be like a balloon in oh
interesting yeah otherwise
interesting
uh and then you have all these other
like thermal protection micro material
protection
um
and i think it's more about that um the
case of puncture
um again i
this these spaces were designed like 50
years ago but um
there are some
some layers to protect you trying to
protect you from that but if if
you know unfortunately this happens
regularly or sometimes in the iss too
there is like a hole just coming and we
just need to
put it so it's it's one of those risks
that are up there and and we try to
manage it the best we can but if if
there is like a big one coming really
fast
i'm not sure we can do something about
it at least it's big enough to knock
your head off the spacesuit is not going
to be that helpful right it's got to be
right there's got to be a category of of
meteorite that meteor that just like
this spacesuit is not
helped uh but but let me ask this
another question
at what point can the
space suit become kind of
uh i'm not using the right word here but
the word that comes to my mind an
exoskeleton where the spacesuit is
empowered
with tools and
and machinery or or software or whatever
so that it's not just smart because it's
keeping you alive better it's smart
because it's an extension
of what it is you need to do in your
environment
so the answer is as today there isn't
any sort of exoskeleton helping you out
but that's the second feature and i
guess that we are
i mentioned three different features so
we talked about the self-healing
membrane and then the exoskeleton subs
exoskeleton is is the second one that we
are trying to implement and that's
exactly um
what you said it is used so hard to move
within this highly pressurized
environment
that we can use a little help uh to bend
your arm or bend your knee
walk around and even if we can think a
little bit more more
smarter than that right like the suit
can anticipate your movements and just
helping you walk naturally
um if if the suit knows that you're
gonna walk and do a certain task or
exactly i mean why not engage the suit
in part of what your body is trying to
do so it's not just an enclosure for you
becomes an extension of you
right right so and and
instead of the traditional
exoskeletons that we can think about
which are typically harsh um
you know hardware and hard and hard and
humans are
never
never good with one another so we are
looking into soft exoskeletons so these
are very compliant materials that you
can put inside your spacesuit and can
make that human space interaction a
little bit easier avoid injuries and all
those things i just realized just in
this moment
but of course it's surely something you
guys think about all the time that
advances in your field often depend
on advances in material science you got
to read their journals to find out if
there's something that you could exploit
for your own needs right so how much do
you guys talk to material scientists
yes i'm glad we brought that up because
i i definitely want to
mention my my colleague and
co-investigator professor rob shepards
he is a professor at cornell university
and i used to be at cornell so this is
why i i know him very well and this is a
project from both of us and he's the
materials guy and he's the robotics guy
okay let's make it in all this
technology
and then i'm bringing more of this space
knowledge and the space component so
he's got a foot in both camps you see
matt i keep thinking you know if the
comedians have
material comedians
they're called prop comics
[Laughter]
those are the ones that have that pull
stuff out of a out of a bin and then use
it for their jokes
they'll collaborate with like an
umbrella glue to a phone guy oh okay
those are the material science comedians
they're the materials comedians um we do
have while we're talking about pressure
john david newman wrote in saying why
does our current spacesuit have 4.3 psi
is that a consequence of the suit itself
or was 4.3 psi a health and safety
requirement granting better mobility
from lowering the psi is great but are
there any health risks of lowering the
pressure on our body in space
well wait so regular pressure
is like 15 pounds per square inch right
14 14.7 i think oh okay i was way off
okay
okay
okay so there's one number we need to
remember who's that okay so 14.7
at sea level
and so this person clearly like they
either know what they're talking about
or they don't they're just coming in
saying 4.3 which is obviously much less
than sea level so
if that's correct
are we susceptible to
this boiling problem under that such low
pressures
yeah so that going back to your question
about trade-offs so here we have a
really really interesting trade-off
between
pressure in the suit
you want to have less pressure because
it's easier to move
decompression sickness that you
mentioned
um
you know we need to be careful if we go
very low and if we do we need to
make sure we are going to um
we are going to
make sure we do it safely and that
requires lots of time of free breathing
pure oxygen
um and then the third aspect i guess is
mobility so pressure mobility and
decompression sickness which translates
into operations people
in the space station now can pre-breathe
pure oxygen
during up to four hours
just to make sure they don't experience
the comparisons again so that that's a
huge investment of time so that's that's
the benz you're describing that yeah
yes
yeah that's what a scuba person would
say was the bands right right
it is yeah it is exactly what it is so
uh we we we don't know of any incident
of the benzene space
but um but yeah it's definitely a risk
and the lower you go it's great for
mobility but then you need to be more
careful
with with this sort of thing okay so so
it so it's it's the trade-off that
you're describing
very interesting all right while we take
another break and when we come back
we'll we'll go all cosmic queries from
our
fan base
and just find out how they're thinking
about our future in space when star talk
returns
we're back star talk talking about space
suits
and we've got professor anna with us to
tell us all about it and of course
matt kirschen just found out where
everybody is on social media matt how do
we find you on social media uh i'm at
mackerson on twitter i'm matt underscore
cushion on instagram which i almost
never use and if you just google
something vaguely close to my name and
bang the keyboard google will find me
okay
and and your uh and your podcast where
can we find it at a podcast viewer near
you
yeah probably probably signs on all the
podcast places that's where we find you
on social media but do you also do
stand-up and things we see you like in
person
yeah yeah i i tour around i'm mostly in
the us these days but i'm sometimes
internationally so yeah find me i
normally tweet out when i'm i'm gigging
oh good excellent yeah you'll find me at
a pest or a comedy club near you
and anna do uh how do we know about what
you do from a social media perspective
do you are you guys active is your group
active online
yeah so we have twitter i have my own
personal twitter and then in the lab at
texas a m it's called the
bioastronautics and human performance
lab
and again i think if you
google my name or or the lab's name or
texas a m space suits um
you should find it there and your name
is anna with one n a d i n
yeah uh so excellent so so i want to
bring back up your smart suit
and just to learn from you
what
what's the smartest thing you're putting
in the smart suit that wasn't there
before that neil armstrong didn't have
as he mounted around the lunar surface
right so as i mentioned this smartsuit
has three
technical innovations that current
spacesuits don't have
the first one what i guess i'm going to
start with the robotic layer that we
mentioned so imagine this internal layer
that is the smart
soft robotic that helps you move around
it's really hard to move inside people
basically have to fight against the
spacesuit and
as jeff hoffman mentioned to me former
astronaut he said the space city is
always going to win
some i'm stealing it's a brilliant
sentence and you don't want that to be
the case right right you know when
that's everything you want the human to
win
so okay so if the suit senses that i
want to bend my elbow and then helps me
do it is that what you're saying
that's that's the future that's the idea
um
and this project i'll say i would
mention this is really futuristic we
were funded by nasa uh with the nasa um
innovative advanced concepts projects
and this is a a program that only founds
really crazy ideas like high risk
i'm familiar with them it's great and in
fact
that wasn't always there i mean i think
people had to lobby for that and i mean
literally lobby but just you know
describe why it's so valuable
and to
fund a crazy idea because sometimes
they'll come true
and right and and the person who does it
has to be a little crazy themselves and
that's okay too
[Laughter]
yeah and sometimes things don't work and
i guess that that's fine and this is
what they want to do they want to find
so they are a wonderful
people and program so we were we were
funded for with these guys and uh and
all that to say that we are in the very
early stages and we are getting great um
research and really promising results
but it's still a little bit down the
road um to have this you know fully
functional smart space so that
anticipates your movements and
so when are you going to have a
prototype
we do have a couple of new
subrobotic
prototypes
that we have been characterizing
producing on a table not on a human so
that would be the next the next thing
when can i try one on
well i mean if we get more funded
we were planning to do
um to do a glove prototype
so we can we can implement all this you
know we we need to start small and sex
but sort of integrate all these
technologies that we're talking about
and i guess i never told you the third
one
the sub robotic um layer the
self-healing membrane of the outside and
then embedded in the styled heating
membrane the idea is to have
optoelectronic sensors that are
displayed visually
pressure of movement or are able to
to enhance your interaction with the
environment
with these bulky gloves that you can
feel anything it's it's really hard to
do things with your hands or even
with the rest of your body
um maybe you have horses in your body
that are stretching too much and the
self-healing membrane is going to break
well you want to know about it and we
can put sensors all over
that um helps you with that right and
sensors today are very small compared to
the old days so you can you can be
sensing everything you need right
right absolutely pressure stress
everything no that's good
that's good
okay so so you're saying um i can come
by next week and i can try on a suit is
that what you do right yeah i heard you
say that i thought
come to the lab and we can show you
around whenever you come to la you can
try on my design and it's
your new design yes yes man
yeah
i i'm just going to say does does the
mit cornell one have a little bit of
elastic that joins the two gloves
together so you can't lose them i don't
think
yeah yeah it's smart it's got it's got
their name sewn into the back i've
thought of everything um
you you have by the way with your
questions and answers you've covered a
bunch of the patreon uh questions that
have come in like jesse desmond from
alaska was asking about having visual
data within the helmet nice voice
commands nice okay so it sounds like
that is something you're implementing
very much so
loads of people i think i'd be doing
them a disservice if i didn't push you
further about this self-healing that'd
be good if you can ask mention their
names too i like to know who's right
yeah absolutely so anthony anthony
shaina uh from plymouth um alejando joe
renoso um it's one of the people who's
asked about this um
and uh
i i hope uh there are other people as
well let me um i'll i'll throw in the
extra names in a second but they all
want to know basically how this
how how this self-healing works where
the nanotechnology is involved um oh tom
lindelos also wants to know uh i read it
supposed to have an outer layer of
self-healing material and heard about it
being used in things like rotor blades
but yet to understand what this material
actually is what does help self-healing
mean for material and how does it work
so anna i think everyone wants to know
about the self-healing material but you
you your your
co-researcher is the expert in that
correct
yes yes
okay so so i my sense is if anyone is
not an expert in the self-healing
material it's just magic
well i always think it's a little bit of
magic to me as well
but it's it's really great and and the
the work that we have been able to do he
has been able to do in his lab we had um
you know it's a little piece like this
this bag of um
self-healing material with a sensor opto
electronic sensor embedded on it
and and you can get a knife and cut
through it so you're gonna cut the
membrane and also the opto electronic
sensor on it so you can see that this
technology is going away
and then pretty much two minutes later
you get all this signal back up to 80
percent and if you wait 24 hours the
signal was completely back up to 100
percent matt like i said it's magic
uh
yeah yeah yeah any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic okay so to everyone but anna and
her colleagues it's magic i will take
that we'll take magic anna we're fine
so so is this is this an ingredient that
you can tell us what i mean is it
is it a substance we've seen or
encountered or or not
yeah i i think it you need to know the
right formulation and and and be able to
know
how to put it together and then
make it in in the lab and it's put what
we were able to do
the next steps will be to really
figure it out if this is going to work
in in extreme temperatures oh yes
oh my gosh that's another thing we don't
know yet um and i have to emphasize
there when we build space
vehicles
it's not good enough just to work in the
lab it's got it you got to shake it and
bake it and heat heat it and cool it and
all the
the the lubricants have to work under
all those conditions and the the metals
can't expand too much or too little i
mean yeah i that you can't emphasize
that too much
about testing it in actual um real real
cases real case right real conditions
case studies real conditions right right
and i've just recently been binging on
the isaac asimov uh story foundations
now streaming
and
a big part of it it's just in the
background there are people you can
infuse your body with nanobots
and
they know how to like heal an injury for
you and
so could they just work their magic
they're like healing nanobots and so i
think that's why matt that person asked
about nanobots
it's a nano thing going on there's
definitely been a couple of questions
yeah about that whether it can sort of
fix people as well
right right okay so there's a really
interesting question that comes in from
um rouhan perria cherry from the bay
area says is there anything we are
sacrificing to make this suit so light i
find it incredible we're able to cram
all the tech from the old spacesuits
into this new smaller model but were
there any features cut during the
process so a hundred years ago
the
radio was a piece of furniture in your
living room
okay
and now it is an uninteresting addition
to your smartphone so i i refuse to
believe that you may think smaller but
somehow lost effectiveness so anna i
will not believe you if you say well 10
things we couldn't do because we made it
littler so tell me where are we on this
yeah i i wonder if the question goes
more towards a different space of
concept which is called the biosuit and
it's it's about all mechanical counter
pressure because though when i think
about that that's a very slim small
spacesuit but the technologies that we
are developing in the concept of a
smartsuit are
are sort of added to the current
size
of these facets of so it's not going to
be smaller
but the the biosuit of this idea of
mechanical counter pressure which is
something that we are also implementing
in this marson
is this idea
of providing the pressure with
mechanically just with some
garment really really really tight like
they do for
for fighter pilots right when they go
into high g turns something squeezes
their legs to put pressure so that the
blood doesn't
uh go someplace where you don't want it
or doesn't leave your head when it
shouldn't
right
yeah so these are engineering solutions
to the pressure problem that's it it's
the same concept just putting pressure
really really
elevated pressure but i for the
spacesuit you need to get up to 4.3 psi
remember
so so that's a lot of pressure and
that's another concept that has been out
there for a while and actually dr damon
newman my former advisor she
she has been the one pushing that idea
which is like literally get rid of all
the gas and all the bulkiness and all
the problems with mobility
and then just put this like super tight
garment that actually looks really good
going back to your question about like
we want these spaces to look good and
look you know
and
and that's another concept that it's out
there and i don't think we are ready to
do that much pressure
in in an equal way in your entire body
we we don't know how to do it yet it's
like the concentrate we just don't know
how it's doing
um okay yeah so we're we're borrowing
some of that concept a little bit in the
sense like
remember that um
um
exoskeleton soft exoskeleton layer that
we're trying to do so that sub
exoskeleton layer can also provide some
mechanical counter pressure
to help a little bit with that so we we
are not um
looking for replacing the entire gas of
this spacing with just mechanical
pressure but we can add a little bit of
mechanical pressure so we can
get a little bit less of gas pressure
and help with mobility tips
that's another trade-off that we are
okay
yeah and by the way any good engineering
project will always have trade-offs and
that's part of the
how to become clever as an engineer is
figure out how to minimize the trade-off
but you always given up something uh so
matt just a couple more minutes left
will you get some some fast ones there
james smith from indianapolis says i
wonder if the smart suit has any other
utilization out of space could a
football player or swimmer for example
take components from your invention and
use them in their suits to gather any
physical or outside data to use their
advantage i love it i love it
cool
yeah so any
any use of a nexus skeleton that helps
you with human movement or human motion
it's it's a great application for it's a
great spinoff and for data gathering i
mean if you have your sensors in a
football helmet and then i can measure
by the end of the game how many how much
impulse
or how much you know
acceleration your head goes through
that's got to be very useful
yeah so my and actually would mention
please remind me my um colleague
professor shepard um he's spinning up
some of that technology also for support
applications arguments okay good so it
is happening very good it is happening
then i would have thought also that
stuff would have had uses for people
with disabilities as well uh
oh
interesting on that same note nicholas
lenson says in scott kelly's book
endurance he mentions the hasselhood is
for an astronaut who has to wear glasses
when they do a space walk uh contact
lenses weren't an options he had to glue
his glasses on his head in one of his
spacewalks to prevent them from falling
are you taking visual impairments into
account in the smart suit how would that
work
oh that's a great question and and i
haven't thought much about it but that's
that's correct and actually has
experienced a lot of visual changes
in space and that's another area of
research that i'm i'm interested in but
i
yeah no that's a great comment i'm
actually taking it as a good idea for
for future implementations for sure
cool so you know you don't think about
it if you're wearing glasses inside of a
space helmet and the glasses fall off
there's nothing you can do
this this stuck on your chin
yeah i mean a lot but none of us have
thought of that i'm glad somebody out
there is is on top of this situation
anna
guys we gotta we gotta call it quits
there but this has been fun and
enlightening and very hopeful
for what the future of space might be
like and i presume that you were
describing the good-looking spacesuit it
can't make you look better than you
otherwise would without the spacesuit
right so
i'm just presuming that right right
we'll get rid of my middle-aged man
belly this is the design so well
little sort of like vertical stripes
that's all it needs just something
okay um and it's been a delight to have
you and matt good to have you as always
i'm neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always keep looking up
[Music]
you